how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel today is very
exciting as we have reports that not one
not two but three new characters are
going to be entering the MCU very very
soon in phase 4 coming in and making
their introduction and Doctor Strange
and the multiverse of madness these
three new characters are going to have a
major impact on the MCU one specifically
because she is a direct family member of
Dormammu and she actually comes from the
Dark Dimension which could signal the
return of Dormammu which many of us have
been speculating about for a very long
time since the Infinity stones were
destroyed in Avengers endgame the time
stone was the only thing keeping him
away and now the time stone is gone and
now his niece is going to be making her
introduction and Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness and not to mention
the fact that these characters are
coming in the movie could indicate that
the Scarlet Witch could be a villain in
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness but we'll break it all down in
this video we'll talk about these
characters and why they're such a big
deal and why they're very important in
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU and so
you can enter my giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or ps4 and I'll talk
more about the giveaway at the end of
the video so the first character that we
have coming and the most a major out of
all the three characters that are coming
is Clea now for the Doctor Strange fans
out there you will instantly know who
Clea is as she is a very big deal when
it comes to Doctor Strange and for those
of you who don't know who she is don't
worry of course I will explain this
report comes from the Illuminati dot-com
and they say that they can confirm based
off of what they've seen and heard that
Clea is going to be in multiverse of
madness now Clea is a major deal when it
comes to Doctor Strange she would go on
to become one of the most important
characters to him and his story and as I
mentioned she is actually the niece of
Dormammu she is the daughter of the
dread whom are making Dormammu her uncle
she also becomes the ruler of the Dark
Dimension but she is a huge romantic
partner of Doctor Strange so it seems
like Doctor Strange is going to have a
new love interest in multiverse of
madness Clea originally debuted in
strange tales number 126 and for
she just kind of watched dr. strange
from afar not creepy at all but the
truth of the matter is she actually
watched him because she appreciated his
courage when he went up against her
uncle Dormammu
and eventually she would turn on her
uncle and her mother and father and join
dr. strange she actually was dr. strange
his only Ally when he got trapped in the
Dark Dimension
she went to save him but she was
actually taken captive herself by
betraying her father and Dormammu dr.
strange would ultimately help her escape
and the two of them went back to their
normal dimension on earth there she
moved in with dr. strange and became his
love partner for a very long time but
eventually they did return to the Dark
Dimension where they overthrew Umar
Cleo's mother making her now the ruler
of the Dark Dimension she would end up
leaving the Dark Dimension to be with
dr. strange but eventually she would
have to leave him to go back because her
realm was in chaos and unfortunately dr.
strange was unable to leave due to his
responsibilities on earth so that's a
little bit of backstory about Clea but
why is her appearing in multiverse of
madness such a big deal well for one we
know that rachel mcadams as returning as
christine but it seems like she won't be
in the picture for much longer as Clea
is most likely going to take over as the
major love interest of dr. strange and
another reason is that of course the
movie is called dr. strange in the
multiverse of madness dr. strange is
going to be exploring different
universes different realms and different
dimensions and perhaps dr. strange is
going to stumble upon and perhaps even
get trapped in than to mention that
Dormammu and Clea are currently in
perhaps this is how Clea is going to be
introduced in multiverse of madness now
since the title plainly states madness
the multiverse is in madness it would
make sense that dr. strange would have
his hands full and get trapped in one
and it would make sense that he would
need some help and there would enter
Clea and that's a pretty big deal but
that actually isn't why this is such
major news it's such a big deal because
it was originally speculated that Clea
and Mart were going to be in the first
Doctor Strange movie and apparently they
were supposed to be Kevin Feige wanted
them in the movie but of course as we
know they weren't but Kevin Feige has
recently revealed that they've finally
found a way to make a certain character
work in the movie in an interview he
stated the next Doctor Strange film for
instance features some new
see you characters which will be making
their debut in that movie you won't
expect or won't guess who it is but we
found a cool way to make it work because
we want to make a particular type of
movie there and there was a character
who we always wanted to do something
with who will fit really well there well
according to the Illuminati calm Kevin
Feige is speaking of clea which makes
perfect sense they wanted to introduce
her in the first film because she is the
niece of Dormammu and her mama was the
main villain but there was already so
many new introductions in that film
Mordo the ancient one Dormammu and of
course Doctor Strange himself it was a
bit much to add more characters but now
we have a film that's going to be one of
the biggest Marvel movies of all time
and Doctor Strange is going to need help
from an insanely powerful sorcerer Kalia
is no one to mess with here's a list of
her abilities superhuman strength and
resistance to injury mastery of magic
energy bolts teleportation telekinesis
mind control illusion generation flames
of Regency greatly allowing her powers
to reach their highest peak essentially
you could call her a type of female
version of Doctor Strange so she'll be
an incredibly powerful ally and it seems
like Doctor Strange may need it because
based off of some things that we've
learned it does seem like The Scarlet
Witch may for a limited time be a
villain in the movie in fact it is
looking like it is probably most likely
her that is the one who opens up the
multiverse yes there were different
realities created and Avengers endgame
but they kind of just go off and do
their own thing they're not really
colliding into other universes or
affecting the main MCU universe so it's
not really madness however it is said
that the events that take place in the
one division series wander returning and
her having her two kids and the perfect
suburban life doesn't actually take
place in the real world that takes place
in an alternate reality that either the
Scarlet Witch or somebody else creates
and when she finds out that none of it
is truly real her husband is not there
and her kids aren't real either she
freaks out and has a breakdown and
creates multiple different realities now
this could definitely cause the
multiverse to go into madness and Kevin
Feige has recently stated and has not
been very quiet about saying the Scarlet
Witch is the strongest Avenger she could
have defeated Thanos if he wouldn't have
red fired you
took everything from me I don't even
know who you were
[Music]
[Music]
so if she truly is the strongest Avenger
including dr. strange in that he's going
to definitely need some help and
therefore he needs the help of CLIA
because none of the other Avengers are
that well versed and magic in fact Thor
isn't even that well-versed in magic he
simply has the ability to be a master
over the Thunder element so Clea coming
is a big deal and actually kind of
signals a few things like the return of
Dormammu and the possibility that the
Scarlet Witch could be a temporary
villain but she's not the only new
character that is said to be coming in
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness according to a report again from
the Illuminati brother voodoo is going
to be making his appearance as well
brother voodoo as you may have guessed
as a gifted voodoo sorcerer he's a
sorcerer from Haiti and in the Marvel
Universe he actually interacts with many
different heroes and he even takes on
the title of sorcerer supreme at one
point in time and the comics he's
assisted spider-man Black Panther and of
course Doctor Strange and there are two
reasons why brother voodoo entering the
MCU could be such a major deal one is
that he may not even exist in the main
MCU timeline he could simply be the
sorcerer supreme of another reality one
that Doctor Strange could come in
contact with but another reason is that
perhaps he could be a future replacement
for Doctor Strange as we know Marvel is
building up a new team of superheroes
that's what phase 4 and phase 5 are all
about introducing new characters and
unfortunately there have been rumors
going around that Benedict Cumberbatch
may not return to play Doctor Strange
after multiverse of madness and not to
mention that Marvel Studios and Disney
are doing a pretty good job at adding
variety when it comes to diversity of
ethnicity in the superhero world so
having a Haitian sorcerer supreme seems
right up their alley right now of course
we all hope these rumors aren't true and
that Benedict Cumberbatch is actually
going to remain Doctor Strange and they
could simply introduce brother voodoo as
another sorcery but we'll have to wait
and see about that and then of course
the last character that is said to be
introduced in the multiverse of madness
again coming from the Illuminati calm is
American Chavez now American Chavez is
actually a fairly new superhero only
appearing for the very first time in
2011 there are two main things when it
comes to American Chavez appearing and
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness that make her very important
what is that in the comics she actually
comes from
alternate reality so if she were to
appear in multiverse of madness it would
make sense that she would come from an
alternate reality and there as well
whether or not she would remain in the
main MCU timeline or not is unknown
right now but there is a good chance
because the second reason why she's such
a major character is that she's actually
a member of the Young Avengers now of
course if you've been following my
channel there have been many signs and
indicators that the Young Avengers are
coming very soon and there have been
reports by many of the Marvel insiders
so it seems right now that it's only a
matter of time until we get a full Young
Avengers and American Chavez is part of
the Young Avengers she's also an openly
gay young woman who Marvel is trying to
get more representation of in the MCU as
well so it was a perfect fit and there
we have the three new characters that
are going to be introduced in Doctor
Strange and the multiverse of madness
Clea the love interest and at one point
in time the wife of Doctor Strange also
a very powerful sorcerer brother voodoo
who at one point in time is the sorcerer
supreme and America Chavez who is part
of the Young Avengers and from an
alternate reality three major characters
coming in one movie and not to mention
the Scarlet Witch is going to be in
multiverse of madness as well perhaps as
the villain not the main villain but a
villain nonetheless for a short period
of time so what do you think about these
three new characters and what would you
think if the Scarlet Witch became a
villain in the multiverse of madness let
me know your thoughts in the comments
down below don't forget to give this
video a like and subscribe with the
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to the
MCU and so you can enter my giveaway for
a chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 the
winner gets to choose and I'm picking a
winner at five hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers as always thank you
all so much for watching will fluff